he is the creator of 100 days of code
it's a movement that helps so many
people around the world stay motivated
and keep moving forward with their
coding so Alex how's everything going
with you
hi everything is well with me everything
is going going really well yeah yeah
well first of all congratulations on
product hunt a couple days ago you were
featured on product time and you were
considered the number one product of the
day with 700 or so
uploads how many uploads you have yeah
no we're at the 700 plus yeah it was
surprising and it was really random
because I haven't considered like honey
days of code is not really a product
it's a product in a sense that bullet
journal is a product it's more like a
system of how you go about doing things
it's a system of rules so I was hesitant
for the longest time to actually release
it abroad hunt but I was actually at the
frequent camp with my friend here so he
just suggested this is like so he
suggested just to post it for me and
there was really nice of him I think but
yeah so we posted it randomly it was
like Saturday at 12 so and for the whole
day we got like 11 up for so I was like
ok at least we got the name scheduled
you know like taken by us it's not
somebody he's gonna come up and just you
know can it get the spot but when I woke
up the next day we got already more than
100 a port service I was like did he
dream this and then I understood in the
morning that they actually it was it was
true Wow and put an actual like the
whole next day I was sitting there just
you know watching the the uploads just
to make sure that we are wiki per to be
productive day so yeah different who
actually helped me with this his name is
David Diaz
might know him he's the creator of the
frontend checklist and now like
performing checklist and I think he has
the design checklist and he's gonna
release some more so he's recently moved
to Toronto to kind of pursue his tech
career further yeah so we kind of met
off off off line now
which is nice he is an awesome guy so he
suggests like he keeps suggesting me all
of this stuff that I didn't know about
and yeah we ended up product number one
product of the day which I was surprised
with but I was happy I think what also
helped is that you know when let's say
you were developing a product like an
app and you have to release it on Prozac
on then you have to create like an
article describing it like a video about
it all those assets that don't exist
that you have to have for the launch but
in our case because we've been running
for two years now we had all of that we
had all the articles we had videos we
had like a slack link everything they
need so in that sense even Instagram we
like we're everywhere so it's been
pretty easy to like set it up and just
forget about it because it was like
fully customized yeah awesome well
congratulations again on the success of
the product launch I guess we call it
launch did you know that we're gonna go
out there did it just appear up there so
yeah we talked with David he's like how
are you not here and he was the hunter
so like he hunted the counties of code
and I was the creator so we kind of like
grouped together and just he helped me I
put it there yeah pretty much what was
it like for you know for you to be a top
product I think free code camp was only
the second place product launched yeah
looking back that was a long time ago
and that just totally took us out of
left field we're like hey why are we
getting all this additional traffic it
was like and we already been up there
for several hours so but yeah like what
was that like just deploy it's exciting
for me and
still not sure why it happened the way
it did because there were a lot of
products like released in that day but
also I think it's because we kind of
like did the opposite of what people are
supposed to do like you're supposed to
release it during the weekday because
every weekday there's like a newsletter
that gets out the next day versus on the
weekend
there's no newsletter like there's no
daily newsletter right so people
optimized for a lot of things but they
end up optimizing for the same things
and they release those products on like
you know using the best practices or
whatever so I think one big part of it
was that we released it randomly on a
Saturday that like not a lot of people
would do especially the people who
actually like plan their lunch yeah
Saturday like I can tell you anecdotally
freako camp has about half the traffic
it has on a weekday on Saturday a lot of
people choose to just kick it and take a
day off I guess with a hundred days of
code they're not supposed to take a day
off so maybe many of your existing
people who are in the middle of the
challenge decided to jump on and leave
so did did this lead to a surge in new
people I believe it did yeah we've seen
like new faces and new people on Twitter
especially because it's different
audience on product hunt I think a bit
of a different mindset there's some
correlation with like people who are
learning to code because there's so many
different reasons you might be learning
to go but product hunt is more its
focuses on the making of things so
eventually like you either graduate
towards that or you find a stable job or
you find a job like if you find a job
with Google for example like and it's
your first job you wouldn't just go on
further hunt right away and try to make
your own products until you get some
experience so there's some kind of
discord so that's why I think we got all
those makers that are in for the hunt
you can take a look and discover what
hundreds of code is and I've seen
because I see the retweets of the
hundred days of code but I I've seen
like this person joint and the was kind
of convinced lays them on my joining oh
thank you for following me and stuff
yeah yeah let's talk about the part
because the body is really a remarkable
success
as far as Twitter bots are concerned I
understand that it recently crossed a
thousand followers is that correct I
think we have seventeen thousand twelve
hours there for the Twitter blood so
it's pretty big
it's bigger than like my cow sounds like
my first like like whoa but because it
brings more value to people is like
seventeen thousand yeah you had 17
thousand followers that's amazing I I
was thinking like for a bot for a bot
account tweeting that's amazing man
congratulations
I say yeah go ahead sorry oh yeah go
ahead
oh yeah my thing was is the popularity
of the bots is because of the valued
provides because it kind of connects you
with the community instantly kind of
like compared with Instagram which I
think three months ago or two months ago
they rolled out finally an ability to
follow a hashtag which is not doable on
Twitter so like it is doable in a way
that you search for hashtag and then you
kind of find out the details
what Instagram does actually and you can
if you are an Instagram subscribe to the
holidays of code hashtag because it's
just people posting stuff they they're
working on and it's pretty cool and I
think Twitter bot
kind of feels that niche on Twitter
where he's just impossible to kind of
connect to the community unless you like
follow person by person but also how do
you find out about the new people and
things like this and also it's not a
simple boat and thank you thanks I mean
to a man for creating it you can find
him at Ammon himself on Twitter and what
he's done I think he's done it there in
the very beginning of the creation of
the countries of code like concept and
without it I don't think we would have
such a you know continuous in influx of
new people coming in and kind of like
the community sustaining itself so not
just it like retweets people but also it
congratulate them on their success and
it kind of like tries to if they're and
activated or if they're upset it
Wilson's coming to those searches I
guess for for the hundreds of code
hashtag and their sentiments or like if
they use the word upset or sad or
something it will try to cheer them up
with like motivational quotes and stuff
so and like always thanks for following
things so it's kind of in a way it's
kind of like a super simple yeah you
could say like it's a bot but it's not
just every Twitter bot which there there
are so many of them and I think even in
those retweet BOTS sometimes there's
value like I follow one for golang for
example and it's pretty good like I find
about the opinions of people who are
just tweeting about going something they
like found out or some like criticisms
of it and it's always different which
before I was kind of like looking at
those accounts for example like there
was one for like angularjs like if you
were to do anything like do yes like
angularjs bought like retweet and it's
not like it's not the official one but
it's just one of those that I remember I
was like why would I ever like follow it
because it's kind of gonna mmm put so
many tweets that I don't care about and
might mean my feed but I think Twitter
has got really really good at kind of
mixing up your timeline in a really cool
way yeah yeah well the the project
itself the the 100 days of code bot and
we're going to get into 100 days of code
for for those of you who are listening
who aren't that familiar with a 100 days
of code challenge it's a hash tag and
there's a website and there's a Twitter
bot and all these different aspects of
it and of course there's a giant
community and I'm just looking at the
100 days of code Twitter bot actually
right now and I'm gonna drop a link to
this in the notes as well take a look at
that how did the bot come about and
whose idea was it and who like who took
it and rolled with it and expanded it I
mean I see that I'm on me tom was
he's been absolutely critical when I
talked to him about it a lot in the past
yeah he is amazing and I think that's
initially he had that idea of starting a
board I was kind of having some thoughts
but it was like all very vague because I
was trying to think of so many different
things about the challenge to kind of
like formulated better to make it [ __ ]
different use cases but definitely a man
I think was the one who like he got the
idea he created it and then just like
was presented to us as that thing like
oh it's done already so big thanks to
him and he also open sourced it and
there's a lot of people who have helped
improve it improve the bot along the way
as well as I think it's been that
Twitter bot is a part of free code camp
github so it's kind like it's a part of
free code camp so if you're interested
in kind of contributing to open source
you can look at the code like at the
code in this bot and maybe you'll you'll
come up with like a different feature
for it and things like that yeah so yeah
and I think I should mention probably
for the people who might just hear about
the hundreds of code that it's a
challenge in which there are two main
rules one rule is you code for one
minimum minimum one hour a day for the
next hundred days after you commit to it
and the second rule is you encourage at
least two people on Twitter every day
that are also in the hundred days of
code challenge you either reply to them
or you like their tweet or you just
communicate with them somehow and that
kind of puts you into the loop of things
into the community but definitely
another thing I wanted to mention is
that I see a lot of misconceptions about
the holidays of code how it's evolved to
be now versus what I wrote in the first
article and because in the first article
I'm like I'm very very specific because
I was working at a job and I wasn't
super happy with the technology I was
learning so I had to find a way to
consistently somehow learn web
technology so and a zip code was kinda
like an internal response to kinda like
I have to make it like a public
commitment somehow so we were sitting
in a restaurant a famous tree like it
every time but yeah it was just sitting
and talking like I was complaining to my
wife like every day I make the decision
and every day I feel like I just watched
something instead of doing anything so I
suggested maybe I do it for three months
and they probably commit I tell
everybody that I'm gonna do this she's
like yeah okay but what about hundred
days as opposed to like 90 days it's
kind of like it doesn't sound really
well doesn't sound really good so after
that was born the hundreds of code and
because of those limitations that I had
in my personal story I kind of put all
of those into the article like oh you
can't miss today you have to do one min
minimum one hour a day and things like
this but since then there's so many new
people kind of came into the community
that I find that they read it and
they're like oh but one Saturdays I
cannot do like I cannot do anything like
it's my family for example or oh I can
only afford like 30 minutes a day you
can they not do the challenge or oh I
skipped two days can I continue or
should a like restart it and to all of
those people into all of you listening
it's very flexible it's up to you and
you can definitely do anything you want
with it you don't have to restart it
every time you like make a mistake there
is of course some ideal scenarios and
there's also your personal rules like
how you twist the the rules for yourself
before you start but I suggest that if
there's a certain limitation that you
know off upfront you kind of write it
into the rules of your challenge so
let's say you don't do any work on
Saturday okay that'll be one of your
rules but then once you commit to it you
don't you don't also sometimes they
externally or for example just like for
fun but if it's something like you're
traveling or you're sick or something
you can always pause the challenge come
back to it and continue don't have to
like you know I had a cold for three
days and I like lost my 90-day streak
like why what really matters is that you
keep coding every day that's the main
thing it's like whatever gets you into
that consistent
kind of into that consistency I would
say is what you need to do and I also
had another thought oh yeah we've talked
about today about certainty you call it
the value of death but it's for everyone
to kind of understand what I'm talking
about is so you commit to a hundred days
and then you know during those hundred
days like where is that moment where you
kind of like start losing motivation you
lose traction like what what can you do
to prevent that from happening
and my recommendation I think is if you
keep tweeting every day and tweeting
your progress every day that'll keep you
on track but as long as soon as you take
a little pause or like three days four
days it probably means you're gonna like
stop doing it for for forever and unless
you come back to it later and that's the
biggest I think because if you're
constantly and also yeah being a part of
the community so being in conversation
with the people who are also doing the
challenge like either on our slack which
you can find in the hundreds of koat.com
website slash connect you can find all
of the resources there but as long as
you keep yourself immersed into that
you're gonna do really well as soon as
you break break off that's where it
fails and I don't think there's like any
difference between like 30 days or 90
days there's no Sun like like in certain
other things for example if you were to
immigrate to another country there's
some statistics that like after three
months that's where like the stress and
and the depression hits of actually on
all levels understanding the huge shift
you've made right and it kind of hits
you like a sack of bricks but yeah on
that that anecdote the moving to another
country you're someone who's lived in a
lot of countries Alex you're originally
a Russian national
yep and you've lived in Japan for a
while and now you're living in Toronto
in Canada yep would you like in moving
to another country to that process of
moving into a completely new field a
really deep challenging subject domain
like learning the code
definitely I think there's a lot of
similarities you're right and it's kind
of like any major change is gonna make
you really really uncomfortable and what
is nice about moving to another country
is that you can't really go back like
it's not as easy as just stop stopping
coding for example and I think stopping
gets harder the more you do it for
example but still let's say I've moved
here and I've paid for education or like
I lined up some work or whatever the
situation might be it's really hard to
just go back and like be like let's let
this money kinda like go to the toilet
and things like this and also like the
ticket price and everything so it kind
of keeps you there but I think there's
some really like if you can do it at
some point in your life I think it's a
good thing to do because it kind of
teaches you to overcome it's not just a
gradual shift it's kind of like a
quality shift in your life it's so much
different that it's like it's hard to
understand unless you try it
same with coding I think if you first
were to come into the world of coding
everything seems very foreign like all
the terms are foreign you don't
understand
pretty much anything everybody seems
like there's on such a high level that
you will never catch up with them so and
I think a lot of people who let's say
they were in marketing or something and
or they were in any other profession and
they hear about coding they get excited
and reads a couple of logs and they
decide okay I'm gonna learn to code what
then can happen and that's really sad
is they would do it for a month or the
they would do it for two weeks and like
yeah okay that that's very interesting
and then they kind of just like a drop
off and they like forget about that
that's what I think holidays of code can
fix for you if you are one of the
beginners if you want to get into coding
it's a contract that you like sign with
yourself - okay for this amount of time
at least I'll give it it like a fair
shot and you don't expect let's say
you're starting to learn French or you
start to learn I don't know
Korean language you don't expect in a
month that you understand everything or
even like a little bit beyond basics but
people have that illusion with codes
sometimes they're like oh like I just
don't get this like after - like I've
spent a month and they say I still don't
get it
like people spend 20 years they don't
get some certain like parts of it it's
all and it's layered I think it was one
of your articles or well maybe I could
you be interview and it was eye-opening
to me at least at the time it was like a
year ago or so you were talking about
how coding is so multi-layered and then
it's almost equally difficult to do
something like systems programming like
closer to the to the metal as it is to
do something that's very abstract that's
even though I it seems to beginners and
like me it seemed that oh that stuff is
like unlearn about I should be like okay
with doing at least this kind of stuff
like still JavaScript but I should never
go into that like it's even more
difficult but I think it's not more
difficult it's just differently
difficult it's a different kind of area
it's kind of like if you were to learn
and study astronomy or versus like I
don't know something like microscope
it's just different different mm airiest
of it so if you're a beginner that's
another I think misconception people
have is that you must learn a certain
thing like you must learn web
development and then we your career if
you're not a CS major but no you can get
into this field by learning web
development because it's the fastest way
and there's most resources available but
you are allowed to like look around and
do other stuff as well yeah and one of
the things I tell people who are
starting with free cooking up for
example is like this is a good
place to start it's a good foundation
learning how the web works learning how
to build basic web apps that you can
share with your friends easily they
don't need to install anything they
could just go to a URL check it out good
way to get feedback and learn some
basics and then if you want you can
learn how to write your own compiler or
your own operating system or all those
classic chemic computer science projects
that people would do if they were doing
like a doctorate in computer science or
something like that there's nothing
stopping you but so 100 days it could
one of the big objectives is just to
keep people motivated in and it serves
as a commitment device to prevent them
from kind of fizzling out 30 days yeah
going all the real yeah right so it's a
way to catch capture them when they're
enthusiastic early on and they've got
that initial burst of motivation and
lock it in for the following hundred
days mm-hmm so I think yeah yep
so how do you go about getting people to
actually commit to this if somebody were
listening right now and they wanted to
there they're just starting coding and
they're really enthusiastic now but they
know that as they have failing tests and
error messages a little bit rate how can
they commit to something like a hundred
days of code and force themselves to
power through the setbacks all right so
there's a couple of things first thing
I've talked about already so I won't
spend too much time on it is the
community is very important then other
ideas I have for this kind of stuff is
first you have to immerse yourself into
not only the successes of other people
like if you follow this like coding
stars on Twitter only you kind of have a
skewed perception of what coding is and
also I would suggest find and read
stories about people who already learned
to code and especially stories of people
who have learned to code on their own
because you'll see the common themes and
you'll see that it's not just you like
and you're not down and you're not like
stupid and because these are all the
fears that people are getting and like
oh I've hid this error like I don't know
what to do with it
but usually with time at least I found
this for myself
um you even resupport like you start
responding to error messages differently
like okay like this is what it says what
can I do with it and you find out what
it says usually it's your solution it's
not as scary so if something is failing
is not it's like I guess 99% of coding
is your tests failing your coding is
failing like once it works it's done
like there's no like unless it's like a
build out of an app or or a website
you're just like building stuff out can
like flashing it out you get that
feeling of mmm I don't know the momentum
but also they're part of like another
more important part of coding is that
once you like build the skeleton it's to
fill it in with like some meat and some
content and this is usually where the
problems happen and it's absolutely fine
that they do that's another point and
the third kind of what holidays of code
can do for you or other things like this
is elimination of decision-making in
terms of what do I do daily like your
habits should never should have it be a
decision like it
the beauty of committing to something
for longest like for a long period of
time with having a plan is that you
commit once you like will spend today in
frustration or maybe a week and
frustration and learning about the sites
you get excited and you make that
commitment once but then it's not like
every day you have to wake up and or
should it go today if you didn't know it
me and this is me and exercise like
that's why I can't really exercise
properly because I don't have a plan and
I'm like always and I see that in myself
right so I see I try to like be self
aware of this but that's what's fails
for me is that for me
it's every time I have to make the
decision and every time I can
rationalize myself out of it but if it's
not something you rationalize you just
sit down and like put your hands on the
keyboard and you just start typing
something that's kind of what it is and
I think we talked about before the call
we talked about the book recommendations
so I don't have it with me this I have a
lot of books today that I'm going to
show but the ultimate one that I really
like I've given to my boss to read it's
the war of art by Steven Pressfield it's
my absolute favorite because I think
there's so many and in it it talks about
the struggle of a creative person to
create art and in our case the artist
code in the case that's presented in the
book he talks about writing but it also
applies to everything else and it talks
about the resistance and how basically
the common themes of any struggle to
produce something new so that's a book I
would definitely recommend you read and
it will give you a different perspective
or like all those struggles look you
feel like oh it's bad it's not bad it's
just it's hard yeah and I can second
that that's one of my favorite books you
know procrastination seems like a pretty
innocuous problem it's kind of almost a
joke like Oh supposed to do my homework
I'll just I'll just do it all at the
last minute because then I have that
time pressure it's all good you know but
you know that's not particularly healthy
but what's what's even worse is when
you're depending on your own effort and
there's no external pressure to tell you
you have to give up and do this you
really have to rely on habits and
self-discipline and things like that to
make sure things happen and you know in
your current job there's a very good
chance that your boss will be perfectly
happy for you to stay focused on your
work and what doing what it is you do
rather than learning an entire new skill
set and probably giving a job somewhere
else or changing to a different
department one's the company or
something like that so if anything you
have you know negative reinforcement to
actually sit down and and develop this
new skill set
what are some of the other books you got
there I'm really curious to see oh yeah
oh yeah so um which one should I start
with so I'll start with the ones I
haven't like fully read I think I should
read like 60% of each of those I'm
planning to finish them it's make it
stick it's a really good book I'm
thinking like the latest discoveries in
neuroscience and applying them to
learning and one of those things is like
that rote memorization doesn't work and
like were you watching that's what I'm
taking from it it's like re watching
tutorials doesn't really work or like
relearning the same things over and over
I would rather like go and try different
resource and things like this and like
rereading especially I was when I was
starting to learn to code I would copy
everything like on code Academy for
example I would copy like the whole
things like save them like my Evernote
so that I would like read it later but
they've never read it and it was like
just taking my time so and mindset is a
really really important book if you
think that you're like brain capacity or
like intellectual capacity is limited
it's not it's just it's a fluid concept
and as you like strive more and you try
harder on like working in complex things
your intellect will like go up pretty
much and it's not that some people are
smart and some people are stupid and
that's what the book can change is it
like I would definitely recommend that
one okay so willpower is a book I've
read maybe five years ago or so and it
was like when this should be authors if
it's visible
so it's bow-bow meister roy baumeister
and john tierney and they talk about
willpower being a resource that you can
deplete with the more you try to exert
it and there were some really cool and
it goes there about mmm what's-his-name
with the magic I forget Oh David Blaine
exactly yeah
like he can be insanely focused like
certain weeks and have a new plan and
have a training plan and everything and
then after he's done he is like his
trick or his performance for like next
two weeks he's like just chilling at
home and like eating chips and doing
whatever he wants and I was so surprised
by that I was like no I thought he was
one of those people that like always
they kind of like a machine but yeah
that was an important book but here too
my favorite ones this yes I think this
book is kind of to blame for the
hundreds of code so there's a lot of
ideas here so it's called the power of
habit by Charles Duhigg hope I don't
like I hope I pronounce his name
correctly and you see I can make a lot
of like notes as I read but some of the
cool concepts in it okay is that certain
habits are very hard to break because
they're part of a larger there's an
illustration here like a larger frame
which is the cue the routine and the
reward so you can't really like their
neural pathways in your brain that
you've trained with so many years of
doing the same thing like let's say
you're smoking but you're smoking
because you have a cue to smoke
sometimes you're like okay you got
stress at work with some project it's
your cue for triggering of your habit of
smoking for example and then once you
smoke okay you've got your time frame
that's a very work you got like you got
to chill a little bit and what they're
saying is that you can't really stop the
habit you can only replace it with
something else so that you like trigger
will still happen all the time
so you can choose something else to be
your stress reliever in this case for
example you can be like I'll just take a
walk instead of smoking a cigarette when
I'm stressed or have a cup of tea or
something so that's one of them I tend
to like my boobs by writing in them and
I've read this a while ago so I can't
really oh yeah I concept of a kiss
it also is amazing it's kind of like
they've done a bunch of research and
they found out about the people who have
changed their life in many many many
aspects there was for all of them almost
there was a keystone habit that started
all of that so it's one habit that you
start with and you do it every day no
matter what and you see the effects of
the positive effects and it kind of
trains your brain to see other things in
a similar framework so okay if I modify
my behavior I'm actually getting
positive results and that contradicts
the mentality of instant gratification
where oh it's nice okay it's good now
I'm done I don't have to think about it
and then the payoff comes with like
negative consequences so in this case
you can a train your brain to delay
gratification and the more you do it the
better you get at everything so having
that Keystone habit you add more to it
and I think the best example I have of
that is Rio by bouta
I hope I pronounced his name correctly
as well of Zen habits dotnet so he was
overweight he was smoking he was in debt
and by at that time he was living one in
the u.s. in like 2007 I think and so he
started this blog where he would talk
about habits and how he was trying to
and he made so many plans of how he
would quit smoking and many of them
failed but then and he's like now he
says I wish I didn't choose the hardest
habit to to change but I think like you
taught him a lot and that was his
Keystone habit and he started adding
stuff and like getting rid of that
getting rid of this car he's changed or
xoring he's moved to San Francisco he
started writing books things like this
so it's it's pretty nice that's it for
this book there's I had four more which
I'm gonna talk about this is a really
nice book that was recommended to me by
another person free code camp so we
don't only talk about stuff so slight
edge and the author is Jeff Olson so the
book
really centered around one idea of how
by changing something really slightly
like 1% in whatever you're doing will
unmask like critical effects over time
and basically each chapter covers
different aspect of your life like
financial aspect exercise aspect all of
this kind of stuff but the main idea is
it's a very simple process of
identifying one thing you're doing
improving it by a minimum amount and
then seeing those effects accumulate and
it's I think it's a nice book it's kind
of like it's fast to read but it kind of
like recently freshman year so this is
as you can see one of the books that
have had a big impact on me and it was
recommended by Tim Ferriss in his book
the 4-hour workweek so there are two
books which I always say to people this
is why I'm in Canada like this is why
I've made that change in my life is
Think and Grow Rich by Napoleon Hill and
the 4-hour work and they together kind
of implanted in me and idea like oh I
could do business I could do stuff and
it's not only limited to whatever I've
been exposed to and so I was really
confident that I can follow
recommendations of seafarers but in this
case I can get it was really really
powerful so the name yeah it's the new
psycho cybernetics it sounds really
really weird but it's it's a nice book
it's been written in the 60s I think and
it's one of the first books that golfers
used and like basketball trainers used
to kind of develop mental exercises for
players so that they would play better
and then it's more like if you were to
talk about like the power of thoughts
and the power of your intention things
like this but it's more of a practical
approach that I think in this book where
mmm you can it teaches you how to
mentally
imagine something before it happens or
before like the results you want to
achieve and that way your whole
personality changes in response to what
you're kind of envisioning so let's say
you were a student and that's one of the
examples there a student who would be
really really bad at math and it's the
reason is not he's like he's his dumb
it's just his self-image of he has a
self-image of someone being bad at math
because it was kind of like mmm
suggested to him over time by teachers
by family whatever but you can
definitely cancel that influence by
making kind of so they also teach you
how to do it they teach you how to like
form that self-image and I think it's if
I'm thinking correctly it's the author
was a surgeon and like a plat mmm would
it go like the plastic surgeon like
cosmetic surgery yeah so and he was
treating people who were injured during
the World War two and also some other
people who were just convinced that they
were ugly or something was wrong with
them with their face and he noticed that
some people after he's corrected their
whatever it was like a nose for example
oh yeah I have it like too big of a nose
he would correct it and some people
would completely ignore that their
appearance totally changed and they
would still think oh I'm like you made
it worse and now I still have the huge
nose so they and he started thinking
like how could this be and some people
would like scars would would be
sometimes proud of those scars and they
it would not affect their self-image and
hence they're also their behavior and
they're being shy of other people
sometimes as others that would just get
scars during life and some people would
get them at war for example they were
proud of them so you notice that and he
kind of went along developing that
concept of self image and definitely
that's something
the place to code where you think oh I'm
not like good at coding him not smart
enough where I'm like I'm only good for
what do you call it like arts and stuff
like that and it's totally different
like ours is as complex as coding and
it's just some people have have been
into situations or under influence of
others that have been telling them oh
like you're not good for this and they
kind of accepted that so now they have
this like mental block and this I think
is if this book is a good way to remove
that block if you want to kind of go
forward and to small books but they've
opened by the same person and also one
of my favorites so I'll show them one by
one this is called whatever you think
think the opposite by pull Arden and
this actually influenced me to create do
the opposite which is like it's still in
development but it's going to be like an
umbrella project or honeydews of code
hundreds of X and all the other projects
I'm developing to be a framework of
thinking of how you can live your life
differently from like the common person
would and this one is called it's not
how good you are it's how good you want
to be and it's also like you can see how
these books are very like creative in
the way they're done but it's not the
shallow creativeness of like oh let's
just make a small book with like a bit
of text and just sell it sell it because
they are there are some books that look
this similar way they're like small and
they're like oh very very motivational
but um this one is actually like it's
bold and it teaches you to think
differently pretty much and how you can
[Music]
like like with protic and if i were to
follow all of those best practices we
would probably not get the product of
the day and like a small example of that
and sometimes doing things differently
will be much easier and let's also
explore they think in the 4-hour
workweek by Tim Ferriss where if you are
realistic you you'll you'll be on the
same level
of like play field playing field there's
a lot of other smart people who are also
trying to be and like trying to do
something but then sometimes you have to
create your own separate category of
doing things so that you're always
number one in it and you continue to in
like you're not in no competition with
anybody because being a competition
competition kind of like it forces you
to play the game of like whatever the
people are doing and you were kind of
counteracting their actions sometimes
and and when you're on your own you
listen to yourself what do you want
like if you're all your friends are
learning to code and you just like and
they're coming along
probably not the best motivation but if
you are excited about coding and your
friends are saying about coding as well
but you're in this case you listen to
yourself and your own motivations you're
probably gonna have a much higher chance
of success as well as like learning
technology Oh everybody is learning
react but you're really interested in I
don't know golang or ison and stopping
yourself from doing that or actually
hinders you because that way you're like
one of the people who are doing the same
thing which also can be good but yeah in
my my personal philosophy I think it's
always better to listen to yourself in
this case so yeah that's that's it about
yeah again like we're going in the rent
success talking about kind of finding a
smaller pond that you can kind of be the
big fish in so to speak rather than just
trying to jump straight into the big
pond and try to be a big fish there what
are some success stories from within 100
days of code that come to mind because
you have so many people participating in
the challenge you write I think at this
point more than a thousand people have
attempted it in fact I can check real
quick if I go to the 100 days of code on
your I think it's still under your own
github account right yep
Loa slash 100
to code and I can see there have been
4500 Forks and if we assume that each of
those Forks is somebody attempting the
challenge because I believe forking it
is one of the steps still this is still
one of the steps yep
so that means too good way to yeah you
keep your journal yeah so 4500 people
have attempted this challenge hundreds
and hundreds of people maybe thousands
of people have finished at least one
rotation I know that now many people do
a second rotation a third rotation
what's a success story from within the
community someone who went through 100
days of code and had a positive outcome
either while they were still in so why
one person I have in mind is I'm gonna
butcher his name but that it sick cuckoo
deep and he is by the name of sick naps
at Twitter so it's syk
and AP s e he lives in Spain and he had
I think he's done hundreds of code twice
by now but he's found a job and he's
very happy at his job but he was a very
like during his time doing the hundreds
of code he was one of the most active
people on the platform also I think
Victoria Victoria Bergquist also then we
have Ryan Yost also who who was also
working at a full-time job while
learning and he's actually helped me
with my other project which kind of
attempts to help people change other
habits called hundred days of X so he's
been helping me with the hundreds of
journaling and it's kind of same concept
but you enjoy every day so we've kind of
talked a lot with them and I also like
to converse with Joe privately or commit
a I'm not sure actually I talked to him
no no them because they make themselves
known they're all over Twitter they're
all there doing things you know when
these are people who could just as
easily be sitting on a couch playing
video games right no they're out there
not only learning to be code but
inspiring tons of people oh yeah and I
think one of the good ways you can help
others learn is just by sharing your
journey and sharing your like day to day
experiences what are you working on what
which companies you're applying to not
maybe not by name but that you're
applying to jobs that you were like just
sharing your journey and it always has a
response in people because they are
interested because they either excited
for you and also they want to explore
what they can do
let me see if I can find someone else so
obviously mmm
me tell a tannin himself who's been
doing the hundreds of Kotick who's also
created the bot for us then I have a
make a hung courage from Germany she's
been helping a lot and also I forget to
mention that in what happened in this
year is that we've rolled not rolled
outs but we've added different languages
on the repo so now we are I think at 12
different languages the repo has been
translated to and if you are on the repo
you find one of the languages you speak
is missing so you can consider adding it
and it would be a great contribution to
open source on github because anybody
can then use it and I was surprised how
many people actually helped us kind of
create those translations one of the
most surprising things was I was trying
to find someone to translate it to
Japanese because I've been learning a
little bit of Japanese way back and for
me it's like an I don't know in an
exciting language and actually a company
called Pro Gate from Japan reached out
to me with with the pull request pretty
much of everything translated into
Japanese and I was like yes and they are
pretty
much like treehouse where they have
courses for every like programming
language I think but it's all in
Japanese
so if you know Japanese you can use that
resource they seem to be very a very
interesting kind of website to learn
from also I definitely want to mention
pie bites which are a it's like a
website where you can learn Python in in
bytes so pie bites I think Bob is one of
I'm gonna butcher his last name I think
Bell DeRose I'm just gonna find it just
by my memory doesn't serve me too well
so I sound bites but let me see I was
just gonna encourage everybody to check
out like I included a link in the
description to the live tweets about 100
days of code using the 100 days of code
hash tag first of all take a look at
that you'll notice that there are
probably 30 40 50 tweets an hour it's a
very very popular hashtag and they're in
all kinds of different world languages
and people are in all different stages
in the journey day 47 day 15 day 8 day
66 so people are all kind of going
through this at different rates and
they're they're all different points in
their their journey but they're doing it
together
and other people are jumping on and
replying and encouraging them so it's
it's really quite profound the notion of
people cycling through the repeatedly
alright another cool way to find out
some of the stories of people is if you
go to product hunt for hundreds of code
some community members have actually
posted their like reviews of the product
where they told their story
of how and just I think it's producthunt
/ post / hundred days of code all in
like what is it called
kimbap cakes dashes instead it's faces
I'm gonna I'm gonna go ahead and add
that link to the to the description real
quick big so people can read some of
those there yeah
so I doesn't affect the the fact that
the streams going on at the moment
coming back to pie bites
I found the creators is Bob Belcher boss
is one of the creators and I think he's
working with the Julian Sequeira on this
and they've created like a course for
hungies of code like where you can learn
things so as you know holidays of code
doesn't have like a certain like
curriculum it has a free code camp
curriculum as I like but it doesn't have
content so people often ask me like what
should I do for my hand a zip code like
is there a plan I'm like yeah just go to
free code camp and that's the plan but
otherwise you're definitely encouraged
to use any resources that you can and if
you're learning a new technology
definitely you can consider that's a
part of the challenge that's another
question I remember that a lot of people
are asking
but yeah so PI bi it's their course I
think the first 10 PI bites are free and
then if you decide it's like a paid
course where you can learn Python which
is amazing and that'll be like also your
countries of code journey and if you're
interested in Python specifically so
yeah that's one of the things I wanted
to mention for sure there was something
else well how about we talk about the
slack chat so you've mostly been based
on Twitter and that's still the main hub
great use a slack channel and you have a
discord channel right yep all of those
you can find on the main website the
hundreds of code that cons let's connect
back on slack we now have around 3,000
people
I think I mean even I can check mr.
slick yeah and how are people
interacting on the slack like it do you
have regulars or do people jump in when
they have a question what what are the
main things you find people discussing
on that so they're just sometimes people
like introduce themselves and talk about
different things random things like the
questions that may have and we have
pretty much a channel within our slack
we have a channel for everything you
might need like if you're stuck on on a
code problem there's like ask for help
there's ask for feedback where you've
completed something there's a let me
just check connect by tech where people
can connect by a certain technology that
we use a there's get motivated channel
where people just like food motivational
stuff in and share resources is a good
one
so when you join I think it kind of adds
you to all those channels by default and
then you can kind of like pick and
choose whichever ones
else you want but I would say it's a
good resource where you need a certain
question answered as opposed to Twitter
sometimes it's kind of like you've
tweeted something somebody responded to
it and then it's lost forever in the
story timeline so that's why we needed
slack where conversations are more
permanent they're not super permanent
because it's a free slack we're not
paying for it so only the ten thousand
messages I think are saved which is okay
like I don't intend to like run the
biggest archive on the Internet
but there's one just out of curiosity
this more we started using that a lot
more we still use git er but like I
created a discord specifically for the
top contributors
right eating top contributors and one of
the appeals of discord other than the
fact that it's just a really really well
built app is that there's no you know
it's not like a free tier where you have
messages so I guess I'm curious like
what you think the benefits of slack are
vs. right right who wants to start up a
community which one would you recommend
they use at this point if you were to
start coming
to use this cord if you were in our case
I don't want like the first 3,000 people
that have registered and slack to just
go off and like download another app
because the cost of switching is too
high and nobody will do it I think well
on our t-score channel what I have to do
is to create those like sub channels in
the more like in a better way and then
we gradually could I think move over
there but I don't know like personally I
don't know how to make that efficient
and how to like avoid duplication of
content and how to avoid all of that
inertia let's build up and for me like
if I were to download another app or use
it in the browser it's kind of like just
another app I have to run where for work
I'm running slack so that's kind of that
was the logic behind it yeah it's really
hard to choose one of those platforms
because there's always I really like
also spectrum and that was an
interesting one that recently came about
from I think max Tiber the the guy who
is behind stealth components I hope I
got that correctly everything all those
connections that's an interesting one
because it's more like kind of like the
discuss kind like the free code can form
where everybody can everything is a link
pretty much you know and that's what
missing in slack is that any perfectly
answered question is kind of lost
forever in this slack world no a big
motivation for us to focus our efforts
more on the forum because you answer a
question one time and then you shouldn't
show ZUP in the search results and it's
a good role and it just reduces the
redundancy that's it and what people
want to have a unique answer to their
specific question and it feels really
good to have somebody giving you exactly
exactly what you're asking as opposed to
your questions kind of similar to this
we the free cooking forum if you started
to ask question they'll steer you toward
questions that it thinks are similar but
yeah definitely like the the real-time
nature of chapters like up kind of a
height and
just a lot of buzz around having an
instantaneous response from somebody
right and I think we should kind of we
should try to dissuade us from doing
that because it builds bad habits of
again it's instant gratification like I
don't need to and that's why even on
Twitter or an email don't expect someone
to respond to you right away they will
respond in their own time where they
they've scheduled it and I think in some
ways technology's kind of like really
yes in that sense where like if I'm not
getting an answer in like one hour
does a person hate me or like do they
have something against me like no they
just live in their life and same with
those instant instant messages and I
think if you are if you find yourself I
think you're doing it really well but
I'm speaking to the audience
if you find yourself being asked or if
somebody asks you the same question over
and over like let's say you go to a free
good can meet up at yours in your city
and somebody keeps asking you the same
question it may be a good idea to put
that answer into a form of a blog post
and have like some sort of like your own
domain slash that blog post where you
can kind of send people to and even they
have more questions you can like a
specific details or like answer the
specific details about their question
but in this sense also what you get is
visibility of this answer for everybody
on the Internet and that can help you
and that can help them people who don't
have access to you in particular for
example like I saw your article
yesterday about deleting all of the old
tweets and I was like this is probably a
question that gets asked a lot I'm like
this is a good idea to answer that yeah
so let's briefly talk about the future
of 100 days of code what are some
aspects of 100 days of code that you're
really excited about he what do you have
in store for the remainder of 2018 I
don't have anything particular in store
but I think we could definitely add some
like learning paths for people that are
you know it's just a beginner you're
doing this or you already on a different
track or you want to learn Python for
this kind of stuff so for us to have
some sort of a way to give them some
content like oh this is what you can do
that they don't have to search for that
would be a good idea adding more
languages would be another and I have
some other ideas as well on kind of like
revenant all around that do the opposite
platform where I'm thinking of starting
a podcast ideally where one of the
topics will be holidays of code and
where we can explore like learning to
code in more depth let's kind of like on
my list of things I would like to do I
have an idea for you just take this with
a grain of salt because it would involve
work on your part but a [ __ ] come on
but it's human psychology and motivation
and habit formation and those different
aspects of applied psychology mm-hmm you
could perhaps consider creating a book
club because I know a lot of people who
are raised in willpower and healthy
habits and things like that and a lot of
it is domain independent whether you're
trying to learn to code yeah whether
you're trying to write more and cool
things or meditate more or wherever it
is sleep more homework to do to make
your life better whether this career
based or lifestyle based um it seems
like that reading you could build a
reading list and then you could have
kind of a book club like in October
we're gonna be talking about this book
and no we're gonna be talking about this
book so everybody get this book and read
it in advance of that that's kind of
like what clubs are as old as books are
yeah for sure
I mean considering it but if I can send
a link somehow here I'll send it to you
in this chat here I'm seeing
so this is my and like a little
newsletter that I'm sending out I've
only sent it a couple of times for now
but this is where I'm going to be
building that I think it's a good idea
to kind of tie it with your idea of
reading like reading club where I would
announce the things we're reading in
that one great well I'm gonna go ahead
and share that as well thank you what's
the sign up with that I just signed up
myself now the pressure yeah I sign up
to a ton oh and somebody in the chat
just says they love the book club idea I
said on email newsletters it's a great
way to I mean the information just comes
to you and usually if I don't have time
I just archive it you know it's not a
big deal right yeah I basically treat my
inbox a lot of people ask me how I stay
up on all all the different things
because I get from Jason callimachus at
this week in startups
he has like inside calm and they have
some great newsletters you know Bruce
Schneider has his cryptogram that comes
out every month and that talks about
security well it's so convenient to just
sign up for these people's newsletters
and have the great information come
directly to you right and and of course
I have my own email blast that goes out
to everybody who signs up for free code
camp and I'm going to start sending that
out again soon yeah but yeah I think
that that's really like an under
utilized medium for people is just
sending emails right and I would
encourage everybody who's watching this
if you're interested in building your
reputation as a developer you know
blogging podcasting these are great ways
to do it and then you can also publicize
your blog's in your podcasts by having
an email list even if they're only like
a hundred people on that email list and
most of them are your relatives and
friends who signed up that's great you
know because it's a low-friction way for
you to quickly kind of share stuff and
it's
more rich than Twitter if you tweet
stuff out people are gonna miss it yeah
yeah on Facebook well I for one don't
even really use Facebook anymore unless
I absolutely have to and I think a lot
of people just downgrade and call their
unit numbers in Europe a lot of people
in Europe and stuff using Facebook too
but yeah like uh sorry for the little
aggression I don't know it's really
interesting to me yeah I would say um
you know having a regular mailing list
would be great for other people and I'm
signed up for your email Alex and
extremely jazz to see what you send out
and if you have a book club I happen to
spend a tremendous time a tremendous
amount of time running and I listen to
books while I run I probably listen to
twenty or thirty hours of audio content
a week like between all the different
podcasts so you know I'd be I'd be
interested yeah audiobooks have been I
think the number one discovery for me
this year
like if since I've started working I've
always had trouble of like actually
reading books as opposed to my time at
like at college where I had so much time
and audiobooks kind of filled that where
you like you have to walk for 500 meters
you have to hop on a bus and you have to
you know walk in a kilometer and then
you ride by train things like this you
can always listen to your audiobook so
this year has been like insane in terms
of like me getting through books and
fiction as well like and had a longest
time I've had all the trouble reading
fiction books and I want to like sci-fi
I love that I've recently read or like
listened to dune and I was like wow now
I understand so yeah and also one little
tip that I got from Buzz boss who's our
Canadian super super and developer my
heroes yeah he's amazing he's actually
teaching it and like he used to teach at
one of the boot camps here but
unfortunately now no access we can just
you know give his courses but he's
recommended on his podcast scene
by the way amazing podcast about web
development if you are going through a
course or watching a video try to watch
it on 1.5 X or 2x speed because you will
not lose any content like I'm watching
all the udemy courses I'm taking at 2x
and I don't miss anything like it is a
non-native English speaker I thought it
would be like oh this is too fast for me
but no actually and even when I'm
watching on normal speed you would
assume that I can code and listen at the
same time but I can't so there's no
really no value for me to like watch it
at this more like slow speed so that's
one of the super tricks and you can
double the amount of content you are
like get through and understand and like
digest and with that just little trick
that's amazing yeah yeah and I'll just
chime in as well I listen to everything
on double speed as well and I found it
dramatically I mean it cuts the amount
of time you've been listening in half
you have to listen a little harder so it
keeps you more engaged and just like you
said I never attempt to listen to a
podcast or listen to an audiobook well
I'm doing something else that uses my
brain it's a fool's errand you know you
can multitask in the sense that you can
run and listen to a podcast at the same
time but you can't like write and talk
at the same time mm-hmm listen if
somebody else is talking at the same
time so the human brain just seems to be
well disposed to doing kind of
unthinking activity and things in
parallel activities at the same time
exactly I've recently found out
especially by having those is that I can
do any work around the house like I can
vacuum clean the apartment while
listening to an audiobook or sometimes I
do the dishes and usually it's like it
takes a bit more time than I would want
to but if you're listening to an
audiobook it's kinda like the time
you've already won and you kind of like
just go ahead with it so it's also been
like a great kind of influx of more time
that they can spend on it so yeah
definitely
yeah and we're in a golden age of
podcasts oh yeah this is like the amount
of incredible content that comes out in
podcast form every week is just too much
you mentioned is great I listen to that
I listen to software engineering daily
code newbie learn to code with me
podcast I don't know if I've cast but
you know any hackers and then of course
like all the podcasts from prominent
technologists and you know tech news
Kara Swisher Rico decode is great
there's no shortage of content you can
you can run for like ten hours a week
twenty hours a week and and learn so
much just with your headphones on New
York Times want you to post like all the
major publications have great podcast
versions so I apologize for the
protracted pitch but if you're not
listening to podcast yet you absolutely
should should start listening
immediately in and you should check out
the free cooking podcast we did where
we're going to definitely continue to
ramp up we're publishing one podcast
every one day I'd like to start
publishing every Wednesday as well have
at least two episodes a week for you all
and it's going to cover a lot of like
stuff that doesn't require a lot of
visual aid so Leslie you know how to
debug this you know snippet of
JavaScript and more right how you know
how do I stay motivated or you know how
do I convince my boss that this
technology decision is better than this
one different situations like the hmm
that's interesting I have just one
question for you it's kind of like
multi-layered question could you tell us
more about your running like do you run
every day what time of day do you run
how like what's the distance and how do
you do it why you do it really
interesting to me yeah so I'm a creature
of habit I've read the Charles Duhigg
book I've read a lot of books about
having formation and willpower and so
every day I wake up with my kids wake me
up basically we start crying
so I grabbed my little infants I grabbed
one under each arm welcome downstairs
get him breakfast change their diaper or
change my son's that over my daughter is
probably trained now and then after
everybody's ready and everybody eats
breakfast I've been skipping breakfast
basically I'm doing what's called
intermittent fasting where I don't eat
16 hours a day and I've been losing
about a pound every two weeks as a
result of this so I'm doing it like 10
or I don't know why it works but it
seems to work I you know just whatever
I'm not really doing anything diet why
I'm not eating breakfast anymore so then
I just just uh after I get the school
and I go directly the YMCA and I just
run laughter on that for about an hour
and then I come home at work and then
after my kids go to sleep sometimes
they'll go there's a lake nearby and I
just run around the lake so you know
anywhere between five and ten hours a
week spent running Wow okay mm-hmm
you've probably read this book but if
you haven't you know Haruki Murakami
is one of the Japanese authors so he has
a book and he's an avid runner as well
as a book called
what I'm talking about when I'm talking
about running or stuff like that or what
they talk about they talk about Ronnie
amazing that's the second time this week
- somebody recommended it to me so yeah
all right well hey I'm serious even if
you don't create at that book club that
list of books put that together into an
article and I'll include that because
you know we could just put it in the
headline like you know the 100 days of
code how the creator or 100 days of code
sticks with habits you know he's reading
lists something like that and it sounds
like you're discovering new books all
the time that cover these different
topics but you know like the zen and the
art of motorcycle maintenance for the
2018
you know people living in that year
that kind of list I think would be super
helpful and you know like that kind of
category was often called like self-help
or something like that but I just want
to make it clear like these aren't like
motivational business books the way that
like you know I think those kind of
books get kind of a bad rap a lot of
these are applied psychology type books
yes some of them could probably be
summarized in a couple pages of bullet
points but I think there's a lot of
value in reading them and I've read a
lot of them and I I definitely think
it's worth you know paying 10 15 bucks
to download a book and listen to it or
to order a used copy for like a dollar
or two on eBay and have it delivered to
your door and you know I think that just
the process of reading these books and
thinking about how they apply in your
own life is incredibly valuable so you
know even if you dispute like the
scientific you know veracity and the
methodology behind how they came to
these conclusions just reading it and
thinking about it is a helpful practice
in my opinion so I would encourage
everybody to give these a try and be
relatively open-minded about it so just
one last question for you Alex
yep if people want to know what's going
on in the world of Alexander Callaway
the Canadian or you know who moved from
Russia learned a program got a developer
job and is now helping so many people
thousands of people stay motivated in
their efforts to become developers
themselves if you will want to follow
you what would be the best way for them
to keep tabs on you I think on Twitter
is the best way and now this little
newsletter that I'm gonna because what
if you like Twitter go down you know in
a couple years but it's probably not
going to happen so I usually use Twitter
at Callaway and instead of ll it's one
one so ka one one away
that's the best way on because yeah I'm
also usually not on Facebook I use it
just to creat like either create or
monitor events for frequent camp Shana
but otherwise I don't really have a use
for it so yeah definitely Peter it's the
best way all right well thank you so
much for joining us thank you everybody
yeah yeah it's great talking to you
again I had a blast hanging out with you
in Toronto so I definitely want to hang
out and get another aw uh-huh root beer
float with you yeah you won't have to do
Airbnb can live with us all right cool
yeah yeah and speaking of which I see in
the background you got a happy birthday
kind of strung across yeah tell us a
little bit about that oh yeah it's been
I guess I shoulda should've taking it
down by now but on 8th of June it was my
wife's birthday
because it looks nice with the heart
like the heart stays there it's kind of
like little limps bulbs and it's kinda
like around happy birthday so yeah yeah
well belated Happy Birthday is your wife
Donna oh by the way she's learning to
code as well she has finally succumbed
[Laughter]
yeah so we're gonna be like a developer
a family that's great man well I hope
you all have a beautiful weekend
together I hope you all get plenty of
coding in and you get plenty of exercise
I'm gonna run soon yeah for sure good
book on running this is both
motivational and kind of instructive is
is called I think it's called Born to
Run like the like the song it talks
about talks about forefoot running where
you run it in your fore feet and said
like most people run on their heels
anything it kind of like yeah your knees
like a lot more the impact is absorbed
by your knees if you run on kind of the
balls of your feet most of its absorbed
by your the tendons in your lower leg so
that was one of the big breakthroughs
that allowed me
at 37 you know I started running
probably you know seriously when I was
about 30
but already and my knees were kind of
like giving me grief after don't run
but ever since I switched to running on
my four feet I've had no problems so a
lot of people say oh I can't run you
know my knees are bad I would encourage
them I'm not saying that like no your
legs are fine just go do it
if you're having serious issues with
your legs I would definitely go talk to
a doctor about it or maybe a
kinesiologist or something but I would
definitely encourage before you dismiss
running as an activity try running on
the balls of your feet and it's a little
unnatural when you first start and your
strides are a lot shorter and you take
strides a lot faster I'm gonna make a
playlist of like 180 bpm music that I
listen to when I run but it really does
work and I have had basically zero leg
pain since I started doing that and I do
you know at one point I was doing like a
hundred kilometres a week so yeah that's
a look alright
check out that book thank you for the
recommendation yeah I have a beautiful
weekend and hey everybody who's watching
thanks for tuning in thank you so much
happy coding everyone Cheers
bye